Générique
- Kathia Gilder: Bonjour à tous
et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition de "Parlement hebdo",
la semaine parlementaire sous le
regard de notre invitée.
- Alexandre Poussart: On accueille
Sandrine Rousseau.
- Kathia Gilder: La question du
maintien de l'ordre est donc à la
une, avec des échanges au vitriol
à l'Assemblée comme au Sénat dans
un contexte social tendu et de
violence à Sainte-Soline.
Gérald Darmanin sera auditionné
devant les députés.
La contestation sociale ne faiblit
pas.
Les syndicats sont invités à
Matignon la semaine prochaine.
Une nouvelle journée de
mobilisation est prévue.
Le sujet de la fin de vie était à
l'ordre du jour.
Un bilan, mais pas encore de
propositions pour une aide active
à mourir.
- Alexandre Poussart: Retour
d'abord sur le plan de gestion de
l'eau présenté jeudi par le
président de la République.
- Comme nous l'avons fait pour
l'énergie, nous allons demander à
chaque secteur un plan de sobriété
sur l'eau d'ici l'été.
Les ministres réuniront dans les
prochains jours l'ensemble des
secteurs concernés, l'énergie,
industrie, le tourisme,
l'agriculture...
- Alexandre Poussart: Vous êtes
convaincue par ce plan de
sobriété?
- Sandrine Rousseau: Non, pas du
tout.
Déjà, qu'Emmanuel Macron se rende
compte qu'on ait besoin de
sobriété, dont acte.
Après, il parle d'un plan de l'eau
en évitant d'évoquer les
méga-bassines, les stations de
ski...
On est toujours dans la même
optique pour Emmanuel Macron, ce
sont des efforts individuels.
Les individus sont rendus
responsables d'une partie...
Je crois que c'est le débat qui
nous manque.
Comment fait-on pour entamer cette
révolution écologique?
Cela nécessite de revoir notre
rapport à la nature et de leur
donner un statut de bien commun.
C'est ce qui manque dans ce plan.
- Kathia Gilder: Il propose une
nouvelle tarification de l'eau
pour inciter à des usages plus
responsables.
- Sandrine Rousseau: C'est bien
d'avoir une tarification
progressive de l'eau.
Après, est-ce que ça s'appliquera
aux agriculteurs, par exemple?
Est-ce que ça s'appliquera aux
retenues collinaires et aux
méga-bassines?
Est-ce que ce sera considéré comme
de l'eau de pluie?
C'est ce qu'il faut voir.
Si ça ne s'adresse aux
particuliers, ça rate sa cible.
- Alexandre Poussart: Le président
voulait montrer que le pays
pouvait continuer à avancer sur
des sujets importants malgré la
contestation sociale.
- Sandrine Rousseau: Ce n'est pas
la première fois qu'il s'empare de
l'écologie comme d'une espèce de
cerise qu'il met sur un gâteau
après une contestation sociale.
Après les gilets jaunes, il y
avait eu la Convention pour le
climat, je crois.
Il avait dit qu'il allait prendre
en compte les questions
écologiques.
Ce n'est qu'une stratégie.
L'utilisation de l'écologie dans
la manière d'être politique
d'Emmanuel Macron et dans ses
actions n'est que stratégique et
opportuniste.
Derrière, en même temps, on
apprend que le ministre de
l'Agriculture hésite à relancer
des pesticides extrêmement
dangereux pour la santé.
C'est au même moment qu'au
Parlement, la majorité Renaissance
refuse d'interdire les nitrites
dans les jambons cuits.
C'est du théâtre de l'écologie.
- Alexandre Poussart: On va parler
de la contestation sociale et de
la question du maintien de
l'ordre.
Après les violences à
Sainte-Soline autour des projets
de méga-bassines, après les
violences en marge des
manifestations contre la réforme
des retraites, la gauche du Sénat
estime que la stratégie policière
n'est pas la bonne.
- 200 blessés parmi les
manifestants, 47 parmi les
gendarmes.
Le bilan humain de la
manifestation de Sainte-Soline
interroge quant à la stratégie du
maintien de l'ordre des autorités.
Mercredi, au Sénat, la gauche a
attaqué frontalement le ministre
de l'Intérieur.
- Le bilan de ce qu'il s'est passé
samedi à Sainte-Soline est lourd.
Je le sais, j'y étais.
Je l'assume.
Vous avez décidé à Sainte-Soline
d'exposer 3000 forces de l'ordre à
la violence dans un champ pour
défendre un trou vide.
- Je regrette que des
parlementaires revendiquent
d'aller dans une manifestation
illégale.
- Gérald Darmanin nie en bloc les
accusations faites aux forces de
l'ordre d'avoir empêché les
secours d'intervenir.
Des accusations étayées par un
enregistrement que s'est procuré
le journal Le Monde.
Une enquête judiciaire est
ouverte.
- Qui imagine dans ce pays que des
gendarmes, des policiers, des
militaires, parfois, dans les
missions de service public, avec
bonheur, se délectent d'aller
massacrer un manifestant?
Ca n'existe pas.
En vrai, quand vous recevez des
pluies de projectiles de la part
des manifestants, vous avez des
réactions.
- La polémique autour de
Sainte-Soline intervient en pleine
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites, récemment montée d'un
cran dans la violence.
Dans le viseur des oppositions de
gauche, les interventions de la
BRAV-M.
- Les faits commis par la BRAV
sont inacceptables.
Valentin, 19 ans: "Je suis projeté
au sol, une moto roule sur ma
jambe gauche."
Souleiman, 23 ans.
"Tu as tellement de chance d'être
assis là.
On a cassé des gueules."
- Le ministre de l'Intérieur doit
être auditionné la semaine
prochaine par la commission des
lois de l'Assemblée nationale.
- Alexandre Poussart: Voilà pour
ce sujet.
Qu'attendez-vous de l'audition
mercredi prochain du ministre de
l'Intérieur?
- Sandrine Rousseau: Avant de vous
dire ce que j'attends de
l'audition, il y a quelque chose
qui devient vraiment très
difficile à supporter, pour moi et
pour beaucoup de concitoyens et
concitoyennes, c'est l'espèce de
ton condescendant avec lequel les
ministres s'adressent à nous, à la
représentation parlementaire et au
peuple.
L'entretien d'Emmanuel Macron à
13h avait cette espèce d'outrance
qui ne sied pas à un chef d'Etat.
La manière dont le ministre de
l'Intérieur répond ne sied pas à
quelqu'un qui a menti, qui a mis
ces forces de l'ordre en danger en
les mettant dos à la bassine.
Tous les organismes
internationaux, que ce soit l'ONU,
la Maison Blanche, Amnesty
International, dénoncent la
manière dont l'ordre est maintenu
en France et dont les
manifestations sont encadrées.
Pourquoi nous devrions subir ça?
Nous sommes en démocratie.
Nous sommes dans le pays des
droits de l'homme.
Le monde entier critique la
manière dont les manifestations
sont encadrées.
Si nous étions un peuple qui tient
encore à notre démocratie, nous
devrions nous lever.
Ce qui est en train de se passer
est grave.
- Kathia Gilder: Il sera
auditionné devant la commission
des lois de l'Assemblée nationale,
Gérald Darmanin.
Est-ce que vous allez demander une
commission d'enquête, vous, dans
le groupe écologiste?
- Sandrine Rousseau: Oui, nous
pourrions le faire.
Je vais défendre cette position au
sein du groupe écologiste.
Nous prendrons la décision mardi,
je pense.
Je pousserai la position selon
laquelle il faut une commission
d'enquête sur la manière dont les
militants écologistes sont
traités.
On l'a vu avec la cellule Demeter,
dédiée aux militantes écologistes.
On le voit aussi avec la
surveillance des militants contre
l'enfouissement des déchets
nucléaires.
On le voit à Sainte-Soline aussi.
Il y a une criminalisation.
Il y a des mots comme
"écoterroriste" qui sont utilisés.
Il y a obligation de dire toute la
vérité dans une commission
d'enquête.
Ca nous permettrait de voir la
stratégie et la politique de
renseignement contre les militants
écologistes.
- Alexandre Poussart: Vous allez
essayer de convaincre votre groupe
écologiste?
- Sandrine Rousseau: Tout à fait.
On verra ma force de conviction.
- Alexandre Poussart: Vous appelez
le peuple à se lever.
C'est un appel à l'insurrection?
- Sandrine Rousseau: Non, un appel
à la résistance.
Il y a déjà eu des répressions
violentes sur les gilets jaunes.
Je rappelle quand même que les
gilets jaunes étaient une révolte
sociale, au départ.
Ces gens qui se sont levés étaient
des personnes qui étaient en
première ligne pendant le Covid.
C'était les éboueurs, les
caissiers, les chefs de rayons.
A l'issue du Covid, on leur dit
qu'ils vont travailler deux ans de
plus, alors qu'ils ont tout
donné...
Cette séquence de répression donne
une espèce de rage sociale.
On ne réprime pas de la rage
sociale par de la violence
policière, ou alors, on se met
dans un chemin qui, vraiment, je
pense, est dangereux à terme.
- Kathia Gilder: Gérald Darmanin
estime que la NUPES a un problème
avec la police de la République.
Pour vous, la police n'est pas
républicaine?
- Sandrine Rousseau: Gérald
Darmanin a un problème avec le
respect des droits humains
fondamentaux et avec le fait que
les policiers sont chargés du
maintien de la paix.
Ce n'est pas parce que la police a
le monopole de la violence
légitime, même si on pourrait
contester ça sur le plan
philosophique...
Disons-le, elle a le monopole de
la violence légitime de l'Etat.
Elle a la responsabilité donc de
ne pas l'utiliser.
C'est cela que Gérald Darmanin ne
comprend pas.
- Alexandre Poussart: Une dernière
question sur ce sujet.
Vous pensez que la BRAV-M, les
brigades mobiles, doit être
dissoute, après la pétition à
l'Assemblée nationale qui a déjà
recueilli 100.000 signatures?
- Sandrine Rousseau: Il faut
qu'elle soit dissoute.
Dans le cadre de l'encadrement des
Jeux Olympiques, il est prévu de
passer à 135 équipes de BRAV-M.
C'est une augmentation de près de
50% des équipages de la BRAV-M.
C'est une brigade qui n'est faite
que pour une chose: semer la
terreur.
Ce n'est pas admissible.
Je ne sais pas comment le dire.
Gérald Darmanin doit démissionner.
Nous devons changer de doctrine de
maintien de l'ordre.
Des révolutions comme Mai 68 n'ont
pas connu de mort.
Là, nous avons deux personnes
entre la vie et la mort.
Vraiment, nous n'avons pas le
droit de faire ça vis-à-vis de nos
concitoyens, quoi qu'il se passe.
- Kathia Gilder: Le sujet des
retraites est toujours bien
évidemment à la une.
Les syndicats appellent à une
nouvelle journée de mobilisation
la semaine prochaine.
Elisabeth Borne les invite à
Matignon.
- Depuis lundi, j'ai entamé une
série de consultations.
J'ai vu hier le président du Sénat
et la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale.
Ma seule ambition, c'est de
trouver des solutions au service
des Français et de bâtir des
majorités de projets pour les
mettre en oeuvre.
Toutes celles et tous ceux qui
veulent agir pour les Français
sont les bienvenus.
- Kathia Gilder: Est-ce que cette
rencontre prévue à Matignon peut
débloquer la situation?
"Enfin" ou "trop tard"?
- Sandrine Rousseau: Bien trop
tard, mais enfin.
On a eu des semaines et des
semaines de manifestations sans la
moindre invitation à se rendre à
Matignon.
Quelle est cette Première ministre
qui ne reconnaît pas les
syndicats, alors qu'ils sont élus?
Ils ont une légitimité à porter la
contestation sociale.
Dans les groupes politiques, nous
n'allons pas y aller.
Nous laissons les syndicats y
aller en premier.
C'est respectueux du combat
incroyable qu'ont mené les
syndicats ces dernières semaines.
Nous n'y serons pas.
C'est aux syndicats d'être
entendus en premier.
C'est leur mouvement.
Nous, nous sommes en arrière-plan
de ce mouvement.
J'aurais aimé vraiment rentrer
dans Matignon et demander à Gérald
Darmanin de démissionner.
Toute la séquence est désastreuse
pour eux.
En l'occurrence, avoir un conflit
social de cette ampleur, de
plusieurs semaines, et ne pas
tendre la main une seule fois aux
syndicats, ce n'est pas
raisonnable.
Cela met la France à feu et à
sang, tout cela pour 10 milliards
d'euros d'économies.
Où sommes-nous?
Quand est-ce que l'on prend en
compte le bien commun?
- Alexandre Poussart: Les
parlementaires de gauche refusent
cet entretien avec la Première
ministre.
Ils appellent à marcher jusqu'à
l'Elysée, mardi.
Quel est le but de cette marche
vers l'Elysée?
- Sandrine Rousseau: C'est de dire
qu'Emmanuel Macron est le grand
ordonnateur de cette séquence et
qu'il ne va pas se défausser de
ses responsabilités, parce que
l'on voit, et c'est aussi un des
traits de caractère d'Emmanuel
Macron, dès que la situation
devient compliquée, il accuse sa
Première ministre.
Il a même utilisé le mot
"stupide".
Il en a fait une affaire presque
personnelle.
Il a même dit que son second
mandat ne débuterait qu'à partir
du moment où cette réforme des
retraites aurait été faite.
C'est lui le responsable de cette
séquence.
C'est pour ça qu'il est important
de se positionner vis-à-vis
d'Emmanuel Macron.
Nous ne sommes pas dupes, nous
serons là.
Nous savons qu'il souffle sur les
braises d'une France qui va mal.
- Kathia Gilder: Vous allez tous
marcher vers l'Elysée, y compris
avec les Français?
- Sandrine Rousseau: Je n'ai pas
encore discuté avec les autres
groupes politiques, mais
peut-être.
- Alexandre Poussart: Ce serait
bien que les Français manifestent
devant l'Elysée?
- Sandrine Rousseau: Il y a un
rapport de force direct à
instaurer.
- Kathia Gilder: Dans deux
semaines, le Conseil
constitutionnel rendra sa décision
très attendue sur la réforme des
retraites.
Si le texte devait être validé,
est-ce que ça peut éteindre la
mobilisation?
- Sandrine Rousseau: Je vais sans
doute me différencier des autres
représentants politiques.
Je n'attends rien de ce Conseil
constitutionnel.
Je ne pense pas qu'Alain Juppé va
être sur une position qui rejoigne
les manifestants et la NUPES.
Je ne suis pas complètement sûre
que les "Avengers" du Conseil
constitutionnel vont nous sauver
de cette crise sociale.
Il ne faut pas installer une
question de ce style.
Après, il y aura le référendum
d'initiative partagée.
De toute façon, il y aura la
continuité de cette mobilisation.
J'invite vraiment Emmanuel Macron
et Elisabeth Borne à entendre que
sur l'âge, il faut revenir en
arrière.
- Kathia Gilder: On va parler d'un
autre sujet, la question de la fin
de vie.
La mission d'évaluation de la loi
Claeys-Leonetti a présenté ses
conclusions à l'Assemblée
nationale.
- La fin de vie, prochain débat de
société à l'Assemblée nationale.
Une mission d'évaluation s'est
penchée sur la loi
Claeys-Leonetti, votée il y a sept
ans.
Le constat, c'est d'abord celui
d'une offre insuffisante de soins
palliatifs.
Fin 2021, 21 départements en
étaient dépourvus.
Dans son rapport, la mission
pointe également une
méconnaissance du dispositif des
directives anticipées.
Pour autant, les députés ne se
positionnent pas dans le rapport
pour ou contre une aide active à
mourir.
- Vous voyez l'exercice délicat,
puisque nous n'avions pas vocation
à proposer une nouvelle loi sur la
fin de vie, mais de faire en sorte
d'améliorer autant que possible
dans la pratique et dans le vécu
des malades...
- Ce dimanche, c'est la Convention
citoyenne sur la fin de vie qui
doit rendre ses conclusions avant
d'être reçue par le président de
la République.
En septembre dernier, le comité
consultatif national d'éthique
avait considéré qu'il existait une
voie pour une application éthique
d'une aide active à mourir à
certaines conditions strictes.
- Kathia Gilder: Vous avez été
directement confrontée à cette
question de la fin de vie.
Il faut changer la loi?
- Sandrine Rousseau: Absolument.
Il faut donner ce droit.
C'est un droit.
C'est un droit de choisir la
manière dont nous finissons notre
vie.
Aujourd'hui, cette fin de vie est
trop largement dans les mains des
médecins, de leurs décisions et
d'une sédation profonde dont il
faut quand même rappeler que même
s'il y a des sédatifs dans cette
sédation, il y a quand même aussi
une mort par manque de nourriture
et d'eau.
Je ne veux pas mourir comme cela,
par exemple.
- Kathia Gilder: Ce que l'on
appelle "sédation profonde", ça
veut dire que ça continue jusqu'à
la mort.
- Sandrine Rousseau: En clair, on
met de la morphine, des sédatifs,
et on arrête l'alimentation et
l'hydratation.
Je veux mourir dignement.
Je veux choisir le moment de ma
mort.
Je pense que nous sommes nombreux
et nombreuses dans ce cas.
Ca n'enlève aucun droit à ceux qui
ne veulent pas cela.
Ceux qui voudraient mourir par
sédation profonde ou de manière
naturelle, sans aucune aide, ils
pourraient le faire.
L'expérience personnelle à
laquelle vous faites référence,
c'est ma maman, que j'ai
accompagnée dans sa fin de vie.
Elle s'est suicidée parce qu'elle
n'avait pas accès à une fin de vie
digne.
Au nom de quoi?
Les gens se sont battus souvent de
manière très courageuse dans des
maladies longues, qui les ont fait
souffrir.
Je continuerai à me battre jusqu'à
mon dernier souffle.
- Alexandre Poussart: Comment
faut-il changer la loi?
Faut-il légaliser l'euthanasie ou
le suicide assisté?
- Sandrine Rousseau: Je pense
qu'il faut proposer les deux
options.
Je pense qu'il faut aussi des
structures qui permettent de
mettre en oeuvre ces deux options.
Là-dessus, il faut avoir des lieux
qui soient des lieux prévus pour
cela, où il y ait une forme de
douceur aussi...
Un lieu d'amour pour pouvoir dire
à ses proches combien ces
personnes ont été heureuses de
rencontrer leurs proches, un lieu
paisible, un lieu serein...
- Alexandre Poussart: Vous pensez
qu'une loi peut être votée sur la
fin de vie?
- Sandrine Rousseau: Je pense
qu'Emmanuel Macron a toujours
reculé sur les aspects des progrès
sociétaux.
- Kathia Gilder: Vous pensez qu'il
a peur?
- Sandrine Rousseau: Je pense
qu'il a peur de tout, sauf des
marchés financiers.
- Alexandre Poussart: On va finir
cette émission en regardant ce
qu'il y a, la semaine prochaine, à
l'agenda du Parlement.
Mercredi, les sénateurs vont
examiner une proposition de loi
pour renforcer la parité dans la
fonction publique.
Jeudi, ce sera l'examen d'une
proposition de loi sur la
renationalisation d'EDF.
- Kathia Gilder: Le mercredi 5
avril, ce sera l'audition de
Gérald Darmanin.
Samedi, une journée consacrée à
votre groupe, Sandrine Rousseau.
Vous avez une proposition de loi
pour mieux indemniser les victimes
dont les maisons subissent
d'importantes fissures.
C'est le retrait et le gonflement
de l'argile, une des conséquences
de la sécheresse, si je résume
brièvement.
Vous aurez les voix pour faire
voter cette proposition de loi
jeudi?
- Sandrine Rousseau: Non seulement
elle sera examinée, mais elle est
aussi passée en commission des
finances et elle a été adoptée à
l'unanimité.
Il n'y a pas eu de voix contre.
Il y a eu des abstentions du
groupe Renaissance, mais pas de
voix contre.
J'ai bon espoir qu'elle puisse
être adoptée.
Ce serait un soulagement énorme
pour bon nombre de nos concitoyens
et de nos concitoyennes.
- Kathia Gilder: Ce sera la
première proposition de loi?
- Sandrine Rousseau: Non.
- Alexandre Poussart: Vous avez
des informations sur le coût que
cela représenterait?
- Sandrine Rousseau: Nous sommes
en train de faire les évaluations.
Ca ne se pose pas en termes de
coût.
Ces maisons ont été achetées après
de grands sacrifices des
personnes.
- Alexandre Poussart: C'est la fin
de cette émission.
Merci beaucoup, Sandrine Rousseau.
Merci à tous d'avoir suivi
cette émission.